garry kasparov is a name that will
always ring in the history of chess but
one of the big things that happened with
him was he was such a powerful
personality and when he didn't like
something it showed absolutely and he
didn't like the way the World
Championship was being run so after he
because he beat Karpov their last match
he decided you know what it's time to
professionalize chess that's what he
wanted let's take the world championship
over right basically it was a hijacking
right and when he played against the
Nigel short in 1993 it was not under the
umbrella of fidei but what's under the
umbrella of the newly created
professional chess Association the PCA
and if he didn't like that because that
was their bread and butter there was a
lot of money fees that they got
extracted from that World Championship
match
you were front and center and a lot of
the drama that went on no question about
it
Maurice I think of the World
Championship five game five matches from
1984 to 1990 is the golden period of
chest and Gary was a real maverick and
keep in mind each and every one of those
matches where multi-million dollar
matches and Vita gets 20% nice little
prize no question about it
I remember 1987 they had more than 5
million Swiss francs that's 20% to the
fee day that's 1 million sweet right
there for the V day Gary was a maverick
he was a rebel in the Soviet Union when
you didn't think rebels were allowed to
be rebels I mean wasn't the Soviet Union
just one big monolithic organization it
doesn't allow for rebels but Gary
in 1987 wanted to start the grandmasters
Association the GMA I was on the board
of directors and he wanted to
professionalize a sport bringing
commercial sponsors and he wanted the
chess professionals the top grandmasters
in the world to take control of their
livelihoods and their lives and that was
the GM a and by the time of
1993 rolls around Gary's more incensed
and more convinced than ever that fee
day is not acting for the good of chess
but literally for its own self for its
own bureaucrats by now he's been champ
for eight years oh yeah
he's got the gravitas I mean he's a big
star not just I guess are he transcended
this he's transcended his sport and
people in the common person is finding
out about this guy Gary Kasparov his
name is not maybe not Fischer's level
but certainly was exact or in the
general world exactly I remember an
argument broke out in the United Nations
Council where the u.s. representative
publicly denounced the Soviet ambassador
and called him Kasparov and the Russians
laughed and said no Kasparov the chess
champion of the world it was like lose
or Gary's were very very well known and
he had transcended the sport and there's
no question about that and Gary had some
very specific ideas what he wanted to do
and what fidei was doing was not cool
and him then he plays Nigel short his
first Western challenger finally instead
of his perpetual opponent that's who we
called Anatoly Karpov his perpetual
opponent he had a Western Grandmaster
from from the UK Nigel short and he saw
this as a clash of East and West to
rival Fischer Spassky it never rose to
that level of interest but he wanted to
take that match and turn it away from
what had often been the case in the past
private money or public money he wanted
commercial sponsors and he thought that
London should be the first ten million
dollar match and feed a disappointed him
with the offerings like well again he
hijacked the match essentially I used
that word strong terms
it's correct but he took the match he
played with short he crushed short in
their match
meantime fidei continues to organize its
own matches because it says we're
legitimate we're the legitimate
organization and the schism breaks out
in the chess world and that continues
into Anand versus Kasparov a played in
New York in the World Trade Center first
game right 9/11
yes 1995 I remember didn't doing the
commentary for that and then five years
passed before he finally plays Kramnik
and even that was crazy because sharafat
properly qualified exactly play against
him but they couldn't get a finance
letter for Kasparov versus Sharov writes
that he plays against his student
vitamin vitamin chronic so there you
have the problem from the schism from
the world war two schism which was like
who held the title whose property is the
world championship title
so fides attitude was like hey man were
the official guys it's ours and prior to
World War two it was I don't know like I
know I'm the champion I owned the title
it's me so Gary essentially with the
schism was saying no the property's mine
I can go and do my own thing and I'm
gonna play this guy this guy this guy
except that came a problem they were
back to the old ways where the finances
were becoming more and more problematic
for Gary Kasparov
it's funny because when you think about
the age of the private World
Championships was the 1880s the end of
the 1880s and in that early nineteen
hundred's it passed and now we have the
late 90s and it's back to sort of
private even though Kasparov is trying
to make it into something more of a
commercial enterprise right and it
really didn't work for him the way it
what he wanted it to absolutely not
especially since fidei held their ground
that's AG we're gonna battle as much as
possible and then he faces Kramnik and
that was really a nightmare for him
because he had been playing so well he'd
been the dominant player number one
player for twenty years how does he play
a match complete match against someone
and he doesn't win one game it's a
question
I have no answers for I mean chronic was
absolutely incredible in that magic
Berlin defense is born he played out of
his mind he played the best chess of his
life
forever and ever amen I happen to know
on a personal level that Gary's going
through a divorce something that he
never felt back on he didn't use it as a
crusher and excuse but I will general
genuinely say to you he had his
distractions but you can't take it away
kramnik one man gromek wins the match
Kasparov never gets a rematch never love
ya retires in 2005 of course in the age
of dominance of Kasparov just well T
years 20 years of number-one 15 years as
champion and goes down as you say as the
greatest player of all time yep I must
say as Magic Johnson said about Michael
Jordan when he said I'm the new sheriff
in town you ain't lyin
that was a bad man and he will always be
remembered as truly one of the greatest
if not the greatest ever absolutely